so if it's up to you though MSN is back
together absolutely they're raising
those babies yep they're all back Emison
forever
oh yeah it's so proud of you thank you
this new book is out now Sasha and good
taste what I love about it is it's not a
typical cookbook like you have all
different types of recipes different
party activities you can do and how
would you describe it well this is a
book that is obviously a passion and
it's taken five years to make from
beginning to end and obviously that's
really rewarding I'm an author that
sounds weird and it that's crazy so
weird yeah but this is basically my
personal life brought to light and I
love entertaining I always have and I
wanted to create this book to show that
anybody could do it you don't have to be
you know a really experienced chef or
Martha Stewart to throw a really good
party and and not stress about it just
enjoy your time with your friends and
family and loved ones and I've done a
ton of it and I know the do's and don'ts
so my hope is that you'll be inspired by
this book well we thank you for putting
this all together because thank you the
recipes are pretty simple actually and
you're self-taught yeah absolutely yeah
do you remember the first thing that you
cooked or that you baked that made you
say oh I love doing this hmm I feel like
the first time I really had that aha
moment that I can actually I can
actually start cooking like I'm happy
with this is my banana bread and that's
in the book that is in the book yeah
it's in the book the video to read and
I have a pesto chicken that's not in
there but that was also something where
I started having house guests over and
just started exploring with things for
dinner and things for parties and that
really just I don't know it made me me
happy to see other people enjoy us yeah
do you host during the holidays because
there's a lot of like Thanksgiving
Halloween is it all at your place
usually usually yeah I mean we have big
families and so as far as family goes
we've hosted quite a few holidays but we
also have a friendsgiving and it's
gotten up to 80 people it's like a small
wedding and that happens every year 80
people that have friends giving oh yeah
yeah I didn't even know I had that many
clothes I was gonna say but I guess once
you that I mean that was the biggest
it's gotten it's usually around 50 like
if you add you know as you get older
it's like husbands and wives and
girlfriends and boyfriends and kids and
yeah so it's it really does it does grow
how many turkeys do you make for that on
average four there are some money
recipes in here but I feel like we
should do a little rapid-fire great
let's talk about some of the things in
there your favorite recipe in the whole
book in terms of tastes my jalapeno
bites they're so easily they're so good
the most difficult recipe in the whole
book hmm my adult milk and cookies it's
not really difficult it's just more
time-consuming since you're basically
making a horchata from scratch the
recipe that means the most to you hmm
oh my gosh I don't know probably my
banana bread because that was one of the
first things that I really loved to make
and mastered Hudson's favorite recipe
actually what's your good recipe he's
here by the way do you want to come and
pop into my mic babe honestly would
probably have to be the protein I just
said that caprese oh yes the watermelon
caprese yes so quick so easy so
delicious Thanks no problem thank you
are you basing the kitchen together a
lot a lot yeah it's actually good
because I do the the proteins yeah he
makes a really really great steak
really good could we do a joint cook my
cookbook together yeah absolutely yeah
I'll even master to most of it but I'll
be down I do have to ask you a little
bit about Pretty Little Liars yes and
the perfectionist mm-hmm
no longer with us no it was a good ten
years though it was a great 10 years you
guys have amazing fans we really do how
is it to say goodbye tally I think it's
good I mean I think ultimately I would
have loved more closure for the fans and
more answers for me because I mean I
don't know who killed Nolan I know
everybody has Emison questions so I
think what I've decided is to answer
them myself I guess for what I would
want I think Emily and Alison are
together and they're they've started
fresh and are raising the kids somewhere
and are happy I feel like Alison would
have eventually gotten back and taught
at Hollis and and and just kind of you
know finally lived a more peaceful life
and found herself better my favorite
thing about you is that you know that I
was going straight to the Emison and
it's like buna but I thought I mean I I
feel the same way like I I wanted I
wanted that that to be the closure in
that way I feel like in the direction
that we were going and it was more of
explaining it in a more realistic way
where you know people changed and there
was a lot of trauma that happened in
their lives
yeah the fact that there was trouble
wasn't the you know wasn't unrealistic
but I think I think you can't change
that history between the two of them had
the show gone on another season do you
think we would have gotten that answer
right away how do you talked to probably
want to take
- appearing on the show I was right she
was just busy and yeah yeah you know we
all we all got wipes we all got things
to do it got babies to make I got babies
to make well she is about she's any I
know have you talked to her we I mean
we've gone back and forth a little bit
she's she's doing her thing I'm so
excited for her
yeah did you talk about her about Emison
and how upset all the fans oh I mean not
not really I think we kind of did our
thing on social media and you know talk
to fans a little bit was her and I have
I kind of just have an understanding
about that I think we both know how
important it is to everybody and it was
such a big part of our lives - okay yeah
so if it's up to you though Emison is
back together absolutely they're raising
those babies yep they're all big Emison
forever do you want to want to tell us
what you think the conversation would
have been that brought them back
together oh I think I think it would
have been hmm I think it would have been
Alison being more open with Emily and
really being honest with her feelings I
think it would have been a good growing
point for them when it comes to
communication I think that sometimes
what they lacked yeah those trust issues
I think came down at communication I
think they would have reconnected in
that way had a really honest
conversation and she would have gone
home and left all the trouble behind her
yeah so they were and she might have
told someone to murder somebody else but
that's what I mean people out like that
shocked would have whatever in this
world yes as we know who cares yeah so
they were endgame absolutely and you
think Marlene would agree with that I
think we've seen what agree yeah I think
so
I think she really loved that
relationship she would have she would
have taken care of it yeah obviously
we're closing a chapter but the idea of
a PLL movie has been talked about fans
want it could it ever happen honestly
you're gonna kill me with this answer of
it you never know you never know our
fans are so great
and I mean I always want to give them
what they want um maybe in the future
you know I think we're all enjoying this
new chapter I mean we they will always
be a part of us I feel like we grew up
together and that's something that you
you you can't change and yeah there's
always opportunities in the future have
you been able to cook any of these
recipes for year I used to bring that
banana bread all the time I feel bad
we're like here's three recipes in the
book there's just 300 there's a banana
bread there's many in the book but
Ashley loved my banana bread did she
really ever gonna say yes which recipe
would correspond with each girl at Janel
Oh Janelle really likes my cheese
platters when we were filming
perfectionist
on the weekends we would get together
and I would I would always bring okay a
big crazy platter which is yes in there
you should take a look at it that's
pretty
what about Shay Troy and Lucy what do
you think they would what what do you
think let's see I think Shay usually
goes more savory so mmm I think she
would like the the jalapeno bites I
think Lucy was more so like the
watermelon caprese I don't know I think
those things are crowd pleasers is
really but what it comes down to and
those recipes are the ones that have
really worked for me even I feel like
for picky eaters because you actually
wrote in the intro that and your palate
sort of change it did I mean I'm still
picky with a couple of things but I mean
it's yeah it's there's yeah there's no
comparison what are you picky with I
still have an issue with raw tomatoes
and mushrooms really I mean give me some
truffle oil and yeah you know like the
expensive because apparently and I'll be
just fine but yeah like I don't know my
mushrooms just not it's just not my
thing
yeah weird when you think about when a
tax rates or fungus so much odds they're
good for you they're so good for you but
not my jam yeah yeah it's been a year
and a half of areas it has it's crazy
I'm feelin great yeah yeah I mean we've
we've done a lot we've moved and we've
moved again we've moved several states
dogs are good we're good it's just it's
awesome we've been really lucky to just
always grow together it's you know one
you chapter after another and and it's
just gotten gotten better yeah yeah we
definitely want kids when is you know it
just depends depends on work and what
comes next but you know probably sooner
than later okay yeah I think it'd be
very fun to see you and Shay and Troy in
all easier I know I know it's it's cute
yeah have you sent Shay a gift not yet
not yet do you know what you're going to
say son it'll probably be something
it'll be like a basket
I like sending baskets with a ton of
stuff in it like a little care kit you
are like Martha Stewart I mean it's kind
of baskets you're the ultimate party
planner love it I love doing stuff like
that yeah yeah you see the Sasha Empire
expanding I won a cafe I want a floral
shop I want yeah I want to be teak I
mean I want it to build because I love
celebrations hopefully one day I'll have
some sort of version of a party line fun
I love that for you yeah do you want to
continue doing more acting I mean are
right now looking for projects and
writing projects and there's more stuff
coming up but I think what's great is
we're in an environment right now where
we can do whatever we want you know the
lines are pretty blurry and you can we
can cross over into anything and I I
want to do it all I feel like that John
so then no but that's the new theme that
was like I'm able to write something for
yourself like prayers roles that maybe
aren't out there and I think though we
need more roles for women for sure out
there
yeah is there any type of story that you
would love to just kind of sink your
teeth into there's a couple of projects
that I'm writing that have really really
strong women in them and I'm really
excited about that it's not even
necessarily for myself or writing for
myself it's just just you know I feel
like there's like you said there's a lot
to tell but I'm
I sounds kind of funny but I love
Quentin Tarantino and I feel like he
he's very interesting he does a lot of
things with strong women yeah and I love
his style I love I'm some guy that I oh
I don't know it's it's because he's kind
of more intimate I know I love that
really I really do I love that just
different different things maybe thinks
I might sprays yeah how do we get you in
a Quentin Tarantino movie no you said
you're writing so was it TV that you
would go back to her movies I've been
really happy with either I love movies I
always have it was a great excuse to not
do movies just because of a PLL but I
think I've always preferred movies but
TV is so incredible I mean leaps and
bounds I mean there's like the same
thing no no lines
it's amazing what they've been able to
do with TV so I mean I wouldn't complain
either way yeah and I think with TV too
because you get so invested in a
character yeah you have those fans that
are maybe more absolutely anything I can
build and grow and there's benefits to
both yeah before I let you go is there a
message that you want to give the PLO
and perfectionist fans which camera you
this one right here
thank you so much for supporting us for
a decade it's I mean it's so amazing
you've you've touched all of our lives
and I'm so glad that I've been able to
spread positivity because you've you
guys have inspired that in me I think
that we've all grown together and we've
gone through very similar things and
you've always been there to support me
and I'm always there to support you so
thank you for a beautiful story for new
chapters and I think that this is
something that we can all look back on
as a life-changing thing if you were a
fan of PLL it I'm sure affected you and
it definitely affected me in positive
ways so no no just thank you you have
that
you